[Music]
my talk today is about something maybe a
couple of you have already heard about
it's called the Arab Spring anyone heard
of it okay so in 2011 power shifted from
the few to the many from oval offices to
central squares from carefully guarded
airwaves to open source networks but
before it the hidden was a global symbol
of liberation there were representative
surveys already giving people a voice in
quieter but still powerful ways I study
Muslim societies around the world at
Gallup since 2001 we've interviewed
hundreds of thousands of people young
and old men and women educated and
illiterate my talk today draws on this
research to reveal why Arabs rose up and
what they want now now this region's
very diverse and every country is unique
but those who revolted shared a common
set of grievances and have similar
demands today I'm gonna focus a lot of
my talk on Egypt has nothing to do the
fact that I was born there of course but
its largest Arab country and it's also
one with a great deal of influence but
I'm going to end by widening the lens to
the entire region to look at the mundane
topics of Arab views of religion and
politics and how this impacts women
revealing some surprises along the way
so after analyzing mounds of data what
we discovered was this unemployment and
poverty alone did not lead to the Arab
revolts of 2011 if an act of desperation
by
Tunisian fruit vendor spark these
revolutions it was the difference
between what Arabs experienced and what
they expected that provided the fuel to
tell you what I mean consider this trend
in Egypt on paper the country was doing
great
in fact it attracted accolades from
multinational organizations because of
its economic growth but under the
surface was a very different reality in
2010 right before the Revolution
even though GDP per capita had been
growing at 5% for several years
Egyptians had never felt worse about
their lives now this is very unusual
because globally we find that not
surprisingly people feel better as they
our country gets richer that's because
they have better job opportunities and
their state offers better social
services but it was exactly the opposite
in Egypt as the country got more
well-off unemployment actually rose and
people's satisfaction with things like
housing and education plummeted but it
wasn't just anger at economic injustice
it was also people's deep longing for
freedom contrary to the clash of
civilization theory Arabs didn't despise
Western Liberty they desired it as early
as 2001 we asked Arabs and Muslims in
general around the world what they
admired most about the West among the
most frequent responses was liberty and
justice in their own words to an
open-ended question we heard their
political system is transparent and it's
following democracy in its true sense
another said it was liberty and freedom
and being open-minded with each other
majority is as high as nine
percent and greater in Egypt Indonesia
and Iran told us in 2005 that if they
were to write a new constitution for a
theoretical new country that they would
guarantee freedom of speech as a
fundamental right especially in Egypt 88
percent said moving toward greater
democracy would help Muslims progress
the highest percentage of any country we
survey but pressed up against these
democratic aspirations was a very
different day-to-day experience
especially in Egypt while aspiring to
democracy the most they were the least
likely population in the world to say
that they had actually voiced their
opinion to a public official in the last
month at only 4% so while economic
development made a few people rich it
left many more worse off as people felt
less and less free they also felt less
and less provided for so rather than
viewing their former regimes as generous
if overprotective fathers they viewed
them as essentially prison wardens so
now that Egyptians have ended Mubarak
30-year rule they potentially could be
an example for the region if Egypt is to
succeed at building society based on the
rule of law it could be a model if
however the core issues that propelled
the revolution aren't addressed the
consequences could be catastrophic
not just for Egypt but for the entire
region the signs don't look good some
have said
islamists not the young liberals that
spark the revolution one the majority in
parliament the military council has
cracked down on civil society and
protests and the country's economy
continues to suffer evaluating Egypt on
this basis alone however ignores the
real revolution because the Egyptians
are more optimistic than they have been
in years
far less divided on religious secular
lines than we would think and poised for
the demands of democracy whether they
support Islamists or liberals Egyptians
priorities for this government are
identical and they are jobs stability
and education not moral policing but
most of all for the first time in
decades they expect to be active
participants not spectators in the
affairs of their country I was meeting
with a group of newly elected
parliamentarians from Egypt and Tunisia
a couple of weeks ago what really struck
me about them was that they weren't only
optimistic but they kind of struck me as
nervous for lack of a better word one
said to me
our people used to gather in cafes to
watch football or soccer as we say in
America and now they gather to watch
Parliament
they're really watching us and we can't
help but worry that we're not going to
live up to their expectations and what
really struck me is that less than 24
months ago it was the people that were
nervous about being watched by their
government and the reason that they're
expecting a lot is because they have a
newfound hope for the future so right
before the Revolution we said that
Egyptians had never felt worse about
their lives but not only that they
thought their future would be no better
what really changed after the ouster of
Mubarak wasn't that life got easier it
actually got harder but people's
expectations for their future went up
significantly and this this this hope
this optimism endured a year of
turbulent transition one reason that
there's this optimism is because
contrary to what many people have said
most Egyptians think things really have
changed in many ways
so while Egyptians were known for their
single-digit turnout in elections before
the Revolution the last election had
around 70% voter turnout
men and women we're scarcely a quarter
believed in the honesty of Elections in
2010 I'm surprised it was a quarter
ninety percent thought that this last
election was honest now why this matters
is because we discovered a link between
people's faith in their democratic
process and their faith that oppressed
people can change their situation
through peaceful means alone
now I know what some of you are thinking
the Egyptian people and many other Arabs
who have revolted and are in transition
have very high expectations of the
government they're just victims of a
longtime autocracy expecting a paternal
state to solve all their problems but
this conclusion would ignore a tectonic
shift taking place in Egypt far from the
cameras and the fear Square and that is
Egyptians and elevated expectations are
placed first on themselves in the
country once known for its passive
resignation we're as bad as things got
only 4% expressed their opinion to a
public official today 90% tell us that
if there's a problem in their community
it's up to them to fix it
and 3/4 believe they not only have the
responsibility but the power to make
change and this empowerment also applies
to women whose role in the revolts
cannot be underestimated they were
doctors and dissidents artists and
organizers a full third of those who
braved tanks and tear gas to ask or to
demand liberty and justice in Egypt were
women now people have raised some real
concerns about what the rise of Islamist
parties means for women what we found
about the role of religion and law and
the role of religion in society is that
there's no female consensus we found
that women in one country look more like
the men in that country than their
female counterparts across the border
now what this suggests is that how women
view religions role in society is shaped
more by their own country's culture and
context then one monolithic view that
religion is simply bad for women where
women agree however is on their own role
and that it must be central and active
and here's where we see the greatest
gender difference within a country on
the issue of women's rights
now how men feel about women's rights
matters to the future of this region
because we discovered a link between
men's support for women's employment and
how many women are actually employed in
professional fields in that country so
the question becomes what drives men's
support for women's rights
what about
mez views of religion and law is a man's
opinion of the role of religion in
politics shape their view of women's
rights the answer is no we found
absolutely no correlation no impact
whatsoever between these two variables
what drives men's support for women's
employment is men's employment their
level of education as well as a high
score on their country's UN Human
Development Index what this means is
that human development not
secularization is what's key to women's
empowerment in the transforming
middle-east and the transformation
continues from wall street to Mohamed
Mahmoud Street it has never been more
important to understand the aspirations
of ordinary people thank you
[Applause]
you